ORDER -- THIS IS THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET SUB FIVE OF MEETING ON
PUBLIC SAFETY ALL OF OUR ITEMS
ARE VOTE ONLY ITEM SO THERE'S NO
OPPORTUNITY FOR TESTIMONY -- WE
HAVE ABOUT FIFTY EIGHT DIFFERENT
ITEMS THAT WILL BE VOTING ON
TODAY -- I'D LIKE TO HAVE OUR OF
THE ROLL CALL.
WEBER HERE JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE -- WE'RE HERE WE
HAVE A QUORUM EVERYBODY'S
PRESENT AT THE MOST UNUSUAL --
WILL BEGIN WITH AYE VOTE ITEM --
EIGHTY NINE FORTY ISSUE NUMBER
ONE WHICH IS A MAJOR REVISION
LATE PROP ROTH TRAINING COMPLEX
UTILITIES CONNECTION THEIR
MOTION.
SECOND AS WE MOVED IN SECOND
ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY MELENDEZ STONE.
THAT'S OUT ON A FIVE OH ISSUE
NUMBER TWO OF CALIFORNIA JOB
CHALLENGE ACADEMY IN DISCOVERY
CHALLENGE ACADEMY IS OUR MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED.
SECOND ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES
SAWYER.
LACKEY AYE MELENDEZ STONE.
THAT'S OUT ON A FIVE OH VOTE
THANK YOU.
ISSUE NUMBER THREE WHICH IS
ASSISTANCE TO LOCAL CORRECTIONS
AGENCY FOR TRAINING -- IS THERE
MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
VOCAL WEBER I JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY NOPE.
MELENDEZ.
STONE.
IT'S OUT ON A THREE TWO VOTE --
ISSUE NUMBER FOR THE VARIOUS MAY
REVISION PROPOSALS POST RELEASE
COMMUNITY SUPERVISION POPULATION
AND CAL BUILT.
THE MOTION AND SECOND FOR I
SHOULD NUMBER FOUR ROLL CALL
WEBER I JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
THAT'S OUT ON A FIVE OH VOTE A
CAPITAL LEASE AGREEMENT --
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ISSUE
NUMBER.
FIVE IT'S BEEN MOVED IN SECOND
ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES SAWYER
LACKEY.
AYE MELENDEZ STONE.
IT'S OUT ON A FIVE OH VOTE --
WOULD NOW ISSUE NUMBER.
SIX AND THE REQUEST FOR ISSUE
NUMBER SIX IS DIVIDED INTO TWO
VOTES OF VOTE NUMBER ONE AND
ISSUE NUMBER SIX IS TO APPROVE
THE ONE POINT OLD -- THREE
MILLION STATE EMERGENCY
TELEPHONE NUMBER ACCOUNT AND SIX
POSITIONS AND THE ONE TIME FIFTY
MILLION GENERAL FUND TO ADDRESS
THE CURRENT -- ESSIE TNA'S
DEFICIT.
IT'S BEEN MOVED SECOND SECOND
ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY MELENDEZ STONE.
IF THAT'S OUT ON A FIVE OH VOTE
THE SECOND HALF OF A ISSUE
NUMBER SIX IS TO ADOPT THE
TRAITS PAID PLACEHOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE THAT MODERNIZE THE
CURRENT FEE STRUCTURES THEIR
MOTION.
WHEN MOVED?
A SECOND ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES
SAWYER.
LACKEY FILLED MELENDEZ.
STONE.
THAT IS OUT ON A THREE TWO VOTE
THAT MOVES TO ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN
WHICH IS THE EARLY EARTHQUAKE
WARNING SYSTEMS THEIR MOTION.
WHEN WILL SECOND ROLL CALL WEBER
ARE JONES SAWYER LACKEY?
MELENDEZ STONE.
IT'S OUT ON A FIVE OH VOTE OF
ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT WHICH IS THE
MUTUAL AID.
IS A REMOTE SECOND ROLL CALL.
EVER I JONES SAWYER LACKEY
MELENDEZ STONE.
IT'S OUT ON A FIVE OH VOTE.
ISSUE NUMBER NINE DELUDE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
REMOVED AND SECOND ROLL CALL
WEBER.
JONES SAWYER LACKEY MELENDEZ
STONE.
IT'S NOT ON A FIVE OH VOTE.
OF ISSUE NUMBER TEN WHICH IS MAY
REVISION DISASTER PREPAREDNESS
AND RESPONSE.
SO WE MOVED.
SECOND ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES
SAWYER.
LACKEY MELENDEZ STONE.
THAT'S OUT ONLY FIVE OLD VOTE
ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN MAY REVISION
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT DOWN.
IT'S BEEN MOVED.
SECOND ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES
SAWYER LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
IT'S OUT ON A FIVE OH VOTE.
OF GIVING GOING TO THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH OF ISSUE NUMBER TWELVE
PRE TRIAL SERVICES FUNDING THERE
SOON MOVED.
SECOND ROLL CALL WEBER.
JONES SAWYER LACKEY NOT VOTING.
MELENDEZ [inaudible]
STONE.
HEY THAT'S OUT ON A THREE ONE
AND ONE OF STANCHION.
IT SHOULD TWELFTH -- ISSUE
THIRTEEN LITIGATION MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM.
REMOTE.
SECOND ROLL CALL WEBER AYE JONES
SAWYER.
LACKEY I'VE MELENDEZ STONE.
IT'S OUT ON FIVE OH VOTE
FISCALES STAFFING ISSUE NUMBER.
FOURTEEN SOON MOVED SECOND
SECOND ROLL CALL WEBER JONES
SAWYER LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE IT'S OUT ON A
FIVE OLD BOTH THE BRING THE ITEM
NUMBER FIFTEEN WHICH IS THE VERY
SHOULD ISSUE GRANTS BUDGET
PROPOSALS.
HAS BEEN MOVED SECOND ROLL CALL
WEBER I JONES SAWYER LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE THAT'S OUT ON A
FIVE OH VOTE OF ISSUE NUMBER
SIXTEEN MAY REVISION COURT OF
APPEALS WORKFLOW.
MOVED.
SECOND ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES
SAWYER LACKEY MELENDEZ STONE.
RING THE STATE ISSUED A TOTAL OF
FIVE OH VOTE ISSUE NUMBER
SEVENTEEN MAY REVISION LEGAL AID
FOR RENTERS IN LANDLORD TENANT
DISPUTES.
MOVED SECOND ROLL CALL WEBER I'M
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
I MELENDEZ [inaudible]
STONE.
THAT'S OUT ON A FOUR ONE VOTE
OKAY -- ISSUE NUMBER EIGHTEEN
MAY REVISION TRIAL COURT
RESERVES.
WHEN WILL SECOND ROLL CALL WEBER
I JONES SAWYER?
LACKEY HI MELENDEZ STONE.
IT'S OUT ON A FIVE OH VOTE ISSUE
NUMBER NINETEEN MAY REVISION
SUPERIOR COURT JUDGE SHIFTS AND
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
WE MOVED SECOND ROLL CALL WEBER
I JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY MELENDEZ STONE.
THAT'S NOT ON A FIVE OH VOTE.
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY MAY REVISION
LANGUAGE ACCESS EXPANSION IN
CALIFORNIA COURTS.
SECOND MOVED IN SECOND ROLL CALL
WEBER I JONES SAWYER LACKEY
MELENDEZ STONE.
IT'S OUT ON A FIVE OH VOTE MAYBE
VISION DEPENDENCY COUNCIL TITLE
FOR THE FUNDING.
WHEN I MOVED SECOND ROLL CALL
WEBER I JONES SAWYER?
LACKEY HI MELENDEZ STONE.
IT'S OUT ON A FIVE OH VOTE THAT
BRINGS US TO ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY
TWO DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
AND MAY REVISION PROPOSALS.
IT'S BEEN MOVED SECOND ROLL CALL
WEBER I JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY NO.
MELENDEZ.
STONE.
IT'S OUT ON A THREE TWO VOTE.
OF BRINGS IT ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY
THREE PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN
NOTIFICATION.
SO MOVED SECOND WELL CALL WEBER
I JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
IT'S A FIVE OH VOTERS OUT ON
FIVE OH ISSUE TWENTY FOUR WHICH
IS THE MASTER PLAN FOR
RENOVATION REPLACEMENT OF
ORIGINAL PRISON STUDY.
THE MOVE TO SECOND OKAY ROLL
CALL WEBER I JONES SAWYER LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE THAT'S OUT ON A
FIVE OH VOTE ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY
FIVE WHICH IS PRISON MAINTENANCE
FUNDING METHODOLOGY.
WE MOVED SECOND SECOND ROLL CALL
WEBER I DON'T SAWYER.
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
IT'S OUT ON A FIVE ALTHOUGH IT
BRINGS THE ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY
SIX WHICH IS THE VALLEY STATE
PRISON ARSENIC REMOVAL WATER
TREATMENT PLANT.
SO REMOVED AND SECOND ROLL CALL
WEBER I'M JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
DOT ON A FIVE OH VOTE THAT
BRINGS THIS ISSUE TWENTY SEVEN
CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON
SACRAMENTO NEW COGNITIVE
BEHAVIOR TREATMENT CLASSROOMS.
REMOVED SECOND ROLL CALL WEBER I
JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY NO ONE DOES.
STONE.
SOMEONE A THREE TWO VOTE OF
ISSUE TWENTY EIGHT SAN QUENTIN
STATE PRISON COGNITIVE
BEHAVIORAL TREATMENT SPACE.
AND MOVED A SECOND ROLL CALL
WEBER I JONES SAWYER
[inaudible]
LACKEY NO.
MELENDEZ STONE.
IT'S OUT ON A THREE TWO VOTE OF
FOLSOM STATE PRISON WATER WATER
STORAGE TANKS.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECOND THEIR
SECOND.
OKAY THANK YOU OF ROLL CALL
WEBER I JONES SAWYER LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
OUT ON A FIVE OH VOTE PELICAN
BAY PRISON FACILITY DR.
WHEN MOVED SECOND ROLL CALL
WEBER I'M JONES SAWYER LACKEY NO
MELENDEZ?
STONE.
IT'S OUT ON A THREE TWO VOTE
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY ONE
CONSOLIDATED LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSALS AND MAYBE VISION
PROPOSAL.
IT'S BEEN MOVED.
SECOND ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES
SAWYER LACKEY NOT VOTING.
MELENDEZ [inaudible]
STONE.
NOT ON A THREE OH INTO NOT
VOTING -- ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY
TWO ALLOCATION OF DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE.
SWINDLED SECOND ROLL CALL WEBER
I JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
OKAY THAT'S OUT ON A FIVE OH
VOTE.
SUPPLEMENTAL REFORMS TO PAROLE
CONSIDERATION ISSUE NUMBER.
THIRTY THREE MOVED SECOND ROLL
CALL WEBER I JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY NOT VOTING MELENDEZ.
STONE.
SO THAT'S ON A THREE ONE AND ONE
NOT VOTING.
OF FAR ALARM REPLACEMENT AND
FIRE SUPPRESSION.
REPAIR ISSUE NUMBER.
THIRTY FOUR IT'S BEEN MOVED.
SECOND ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES
SAWYER.
LACKEY [inaudible]
NOW VOTING [inaudible]
MELENDEZ [inaudible] THIRTY FOUR
I STONE.
HEY THIS FOUR ZERO ONE NOT
VOTING.
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY FIVE WHICH
IS THE FLEET AT S. IT MAKES.
MANAGEMENT. SEVEN MOVED SECOND.
ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
DOT ON A FIVE OH VOTE OKAY
CONTRACT MAKE THE MEDICAL
SERVICES AUGMENTATION.
ISSUE THIRTY SIX HAS BEEN MODE.
SECOND ROW CALL WHOEVER THOUGHT
I JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY NOT VOTING MELENDEZ.
HEY THE STORY OF SKEWS ME. THREE
ONE AND ONE HALF VOTING.
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN WHICH
IS THE COUNSEL IN CRIMINAL
JUSTICE AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
RESEARCH UNIT.
SO WE MOVED.
SECOND ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES
SAWYER.
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
IT'S ON A FIVE A VOTE IS OUT
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT WHICH
IS A MAJOR REVISION A MEDICAL
CLASSIFICATION MODEL UPDATES.
IS MOVED IN SECOND ROLL CALL
WEBER I'M JONES SAWYER LACKEY
VOTING.
MELENDEZ.
HIS THREE OWN. ONE AND ONE NOT
VOTERS ARE ABOUT THAT MY SYSTEM.
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY NINE MAY
REVISION INTEGRATED SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER TREATMENT PROGRAM.
REMOTE.
SECOND ROW COUGHED WEBER AYE
JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY NOT VOTING [inaudible]
MELENDEZ [inaudible]
STONE.
THAT'S AT THE OUT ON A THREE ONE
AND ONE NOT VOTING -- THE
JANITORIAL SERVICES ISSUE.
FORTY WAS REMOVED SECOND ROLL
CALL WEBER.
JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY ALL RIGHT MELENDEZ STONE.
WITHOUT ON A FIVE OH VOTE ISSUE
FORTY ONE WHICH IS A COUNCIL ON
CRIMINAL JUSTICE BEHAVIOR HEALTH.
SECOND OKAY BUT MOVED IN SECOND
ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY MELENDEZ STONE.
IT'S OUT ON A FIVE OH VOTE.
WITH DOWN TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
DNA IDENTIFICATION FUN READ.
REVENUE BACK FILL IS THEIR
MOTION FOR FORTY TWO SECOND SAID
MOVED IN SECOND ROLL CALL WEBER
I'M JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY MELENDEZ STONE A TOTAL OF
FIVE OH VOTE THAT BRINGS IT
ISSUE NUMBER FORTY THREE WHICH
IS A FORENSIC LABORATORY
EQUIPMENT REFRESH HELLO SO WHEN
MOVED.
SECOND ROLL CALL.
WEBER I JONES SAWYER LACKEY HI
MELENDEZ STONE.
IT'S OUT ON A FIVE OH VOTE
GREENS ISSUE NUMBER FORTY FOUR
WHICH IS OF A BRUTAL FAR ARMS
WORK WORKLOAD.
SECOND IT'S BEEN MOVED IN SECOND
ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE IT'S OUT ON A
FIVE OH VOTEISSUE NUMBER FORTY
FIVE I BELIEVE THERE IS A
SUBSTITUTE TO THAT -- THE MOTION
IS TO A PASSED THE ARM OF WHAT
IS RECOMMENDED BUT THERE'S AN
ALTERNATIVE.
YES I'D LIKE TO MAKE AN
ALTERNATIVE MOTION TO PROVE
DOJ'S REQUEST FOR SIXTEEN POINT
NINE MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR
APPS.
OKAY THAT'S EMOTIONS
[inaudible]
OKAY.
ROLL CALL WEBER NO JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
IT FILLS IN A THREE TWO VOTE TWO
THREE I SHOULD SAY THE OF
SUBSTITUTE MOTION THAT BRINGS
BACK TO ISSUE FORTY FIVE THE
CURRENT -- ARM TO PROHIBIT
PERSON SYSTEM INVESTIGATION IN
SPRING FINANCE LETTER ADJUSTMENT.
MOVED.
SECOND OKAY ROLL CALL WEBER I
DON'T SAWYER.
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
THAT PASSES FIVE OH SEX OFFENDER
REGISTRATION ISSUE FORTY SIX
THEIR MOTION.
BUT MOVED IN SECOND ROLL CALL
WEBER HI JONES SAWYER LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
SAT ON A THREE TWO VOTE THE
JUSTICE HUMAN RESOURCES.
OKAY ISSUE FORTY SEVEN MOVED IN
SECOND ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES
SAWYER.
LACKEY NOBODY MELENDEZ.
STONE.
SAT ON A THREE ONE AND ONE NOT
VOTING -- ISSUE FORTY EIGHT
WHICH IS A CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR REPORT HATE CRIMES IN
CALIFORNIA'S THEIR MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED IN SECOND ROLL
CALL WEBER I'VE JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
OKAY THAT'S ON OUT ON A FIVE OH
VOTE ISSUE FORTY NINE THE DEALS
WITH SB SEVEN FORTY SIX SB.
ELEVEN HUNDRED SB EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY TWO AND AN EXCUSE ME AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO IN AB.
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT WHEN MOLD
SECOND ROLL CALL WEBER I'VE
JONES SAWYER LACKEY NOT VOTING
MELINDA'S [inaudible]
STONE.
OKAY THAT'S OUT ON A THREE OH
WITH TO NOT VOTING.
ISSUE FIFTY SUBSEQUENT ARREST
NOTIFICATION.
REMOVED SECOND ROLL CALL.
UBER I'M JONES SAWYER LACKEY.
ALL RIGHT MELENDEZ.
STONE.
IT'S ON A FIVE OH VOTE THE ISSUE
FIFTY ONE PEACE OFFICER RELEASE
RECORDS.
REMOVED.
A SECOND ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES
SAWYER.
LACKEY VOTING MELENDEZ.
STONE.
AS THE THREE WISE OUT ON A THREE
ONE WOULD ONE NOT VOTING --
ISSUE FIFTY TWO WHICH IS A
CRIMINAL LAW DNA COLLECTION OF
MINORS.
HAS BEEN MOVED AND SECONDROLL
CALL WEBER I'M JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY HI MELENDEZ STONE SO ON A
FIVE OH VOTE ISSUE FIFTY THREE
WHICH IS SEXUAL ASSAULT
INVESTIGATIONS EVIDENCE KIT SO
MOVED. TO AND MOVED SECOND ROLL
CALL WEBER I JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY ALL RIGHT MELENDEZ STONE.
IT'S OUT ON A FIVE OH VOTE MAJOR
LEAGUE SPORTS RAFFLE PROGRAM AND
T. B. L..
OF THEIR MOTION.
THIS MOVED IN SECOND ROLL CALL
WEBER I JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY MELENDEZ STONE IT'S OUT
ON A FIVE WILL VOTE THANK YOU
ISSUE FIFTY FIVE WHICH MAYBE
VISION CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE
UTILIZATION REVIEW AND
EVALUATION SYSTEM.
AS WE MOVED SECOND ROLL CALL
WEBER IJONES SAWYER.
LACKEY HI MELINDA STONE.
IT'S OUT ON A FIVE OH VOTE OKAY
ISSUE FIFTY SIX WHICH IS MAY
REVISION PAYMENT OF SETTLEMENTS
AND JUDGMENTS LOOP IT'S BEEN
MOVED.
SECOND ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES
SAWYER.
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE IT'S OUT ON A
FIVE OH VOTE A MAJOR REVISION
CARD ROMAN THIRD PARTY PROVIDER
WORKFLOW.
MOVED IN SECOND ROLL CALL WEBER
I'M JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY HI MELINDA STONE IT'S OUT
ON A FIVE OH VOTE THANK YOU EAT
ISSUE FIFTY EIGHT CONTROL
SECTION.
FIVE MOVED SECOND ROLL CALL
WEBER I JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
I THINK THAT BRINGS US TO THE
END OF THE AGENDA WANT TO THANK
THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE HERE THANK
OUR MEMBERS FOR ALL ARRIVING ON
TIME AND THAT CONCLUDES OUR
MEETING AND MS OUR SESSIONS --
FOR FOR SUB FIVE THANK YOU